hey how's it going it's time for a
update and you know what that means
[Music]
see how - Lampe everybody I don't want
to I have an important update I need to
make I just realized I forgot something
oh wait it's right here here we go I'm
going away a friend of mine is gonna
take care of Sleepy while I'm gone I
hope they do a good job cuz I really
care about you sleepy I just wish you
would stop [ __ ] you know I'm going
away to Los Angeles just like I did last
year if you remember have you been
watching that long I hate myself I'm not
supposed to say why I'm there but I'm
going at the exact same time for the
exact same amount just like I did last
year so if you have a brain you'll
figure it out that I'm doing scared
pewdiepie I don't know why I'm not
supposed to say that just makes it
everything complicated for no good
reason
yeah I'll be away for three weeks but I
decided that I was gonna daily vlog
during that time last year I had
prepared videos in advance and it was a
[ __ ] nightmare it's the worst time oh
oh it's coming he's [ __ ] it's a lot
of [ __ ] happening here okay alright yeah
no lies here was the worst point in my
youtube career because I was so forced
to make videos while I was being away so
this year I just decided to daily vlog
instead I'm gonna daily blog I'm gonna
daily vlog it's a huge announcement I'm
daily blog sleepy do you understand the
consequences of what's happening gonna
daily vlog it should be a lot of fun I'm
really excited I'm genuinely excited
because I you know you know how people
call their vlogs something special like
vlogmas or like the vlog ly and whatever
I'm gonna call it Berta bow for
absolutely no reason at all I just
thought it was the dumbest name I could
think of I think my videos have been
pretty inconsistent lately which believe
it or not still kind of affects me if a
video
doing badly I'm not not too happy about
it I think it would be nice for me to
change the pace a little bit do
something different for a while and I
think you bros will enjoy it as well
last year's vlog were very very popular
and successful and a lot of people like
them so I think it could be a lot of fun
to share that adventure with you guys I
will still do regular videos while I'm
there as well but I think the main thing
is going to be the daily vlogging the
bird a bow gonna meet a lot of cool
people while I'm in LA I'm really
excited there's a lot of people flying
in for the show I think a lot of scare
PewDiePie didn't really work but I think
a lot of it some episodes are really
really really funny and I think we
really focused in on what worked and
we're just gonna keep doing that yeah
then been kind of stressing out over me
leaving for such a long time so for me
to be away it freaks freaks you out a
little bit but you know daily vlogging
it should be fun Berta BOE everyone
burnable clap it up it's gonna be very -
very how happy I'll be your hands good
GABA this looks awesome by the way I
just realized how hard you go leveraged
carp on here let me tell you about bar
up oh oh what am i doing this is so
silly this is not my hands why would I
do thank you for always supporting me
whenever I do different stuff I'm really
proud to have an audience that lets me
explore and do different things even
though sometimes it doesn't work
sometimes it does and I really
appreciate that you guys are here the
fact that you guys have been supporting
me for years is incredible and just I
did not think I would still be where I
am today a year ago while doing the same
thing honestly I'm just happy I'm still
being able to do this and I from the
bottom of my heart thank you for
supporting that because you make it
happen by watching my video so I really
hope you will enjoy bar tab oh it's
going to be a fresh new experience
and that's it for me for now stay as a
mess
[Music]